oh
that's a hard no for me dog hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by seed and
we'll be taking a look at controversial
psychologist jordan peterson and the
carnivore diet but first let me tell you
about my sponsor seed so i talk about
the importance of gut health all the
time and a lot of people ask me my
opinion on pre and probiotics so
probiotics are of course the good gut
bacteria and prebiotics are the food
that feed the bacteria but both are
important for a healthy microbiome so i
like seeds daily symbiotic because you
get both a pre and a probiotic in one
capsule together with 24 clinically and
scientifically studied strains the way
they've engineered their capsule ensures
100 delivery of the probiotic to your
colon so you really do reap the benefits
most probiotics end up dying in your
stomach acid so if you've taken a
probiotic before and felt no difference
it's likely because it just wasn't
surviving the harsh environments of our
gi tract so seed is different in this
regard now we have evidence that a
healthy gut with an optimal balance of
good bacteria can help digestive issues
like bloating and constipation immune
health heart health skin health and so
much more i also love that they're
sustainably delivered every month so you
get a refillable glass jar with your
first purchase and the monthly refills
are delivered in compostable
biodegradable and recyclable packaging
so if you want to check out seed
yourself you can get 15 off of your
first month's supply of seeds daily
symbiotic by clicking the link in the
description box and using my code abby
at checkout and you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as usual feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey as we will be discussing a
very restrictive diet and if you are not
already subscribed here hit that sub
button and follow me over on tick tock
and instagram abby's kitchen so jordan
peterson is a canadian psychologist
who's really no stranger to ruffling a
few feathers for a lot of reasons i'm
not going to even touch politics today
because i have enough to talk about with
his endorsement of the carnivore diet on
the joe rogan show
[Music]
i know a lot of spice in one sentence
right there no but seriously if you are
wondering what the f you eat on a
carnivore diet well according to jordan
peterson i eat beef and salt and water
buckle up babies let's dive in and
debunk some of the pro carnivore claims
he makes on the show claim number one
the carnivore diet results in weight
loss then i lost seven pounds the first
month then i lost seven pounds the next
month then i lost seven pounds the next
month i lost seven pounds every month
for seven months like i'd throw away all
my clothes and i lost 50 pounds i'm
nowhere near as hungry as i used to be
my appetizer probably fallen by 70
so this weight loss definitely does
sound extreme but not that surprising
when you really think about it so for
one this diet is just fat and protein
which are two macronutrients that are
very saturating because they delay
stomach emptying and digest lower than
let's say simple carbs also a diet of
literally just one food or food group
with no sauce or garnishes side dishes
etc is going to get so boring and
monotonous then it's pretty hard to
overeat a lot of folks would just end up
eating the bare minimum to keep the
hunger pains at bay because eating like
a second porterhouse is probably gonna
seem like a huge chore when you've
already had a t-bone for lunch and while
i would argue that all fad weight loss
diets are unsustainable the carnivore
diet really takes the cake for one it's
expensive as to me 2 000 calories in
steaks you're looking at at least 25 or
more per day second you have very little
opportunity for any socializing around
food unless you're dining in a
steakhouse where they're cool with you
swapping out your potato for a side of
salt it seems you're pretty much doomed
to just dine alone at home for life
there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats and three there are a whole
host of not so sexy side effects that
i'm gonna speak to in a moment not to
mention when you inevitably throw in the
towel on this miserable exercise you'd
not only gain all the weight right back
but you'd also probably be faced with
overwhelming digestive problems as your
body is forced to really quickly
upregulate all the enzymes that were
suppressed from your monomeal lifestyle
and is weight loss really so important
when your health and legit life is at
stake
no pun intended we know that a diet
that's very high in red meat is
associated with increased risks of
colorectal breast and prostate cancer
and we also know that ultra high protein
diets especially those high in red meat
can strain our kidneys and increase
calcium loss and while the evidence on
the impact of saturated fats is
controversial and mixed
as i discussed in my video right here we
do know that high intakes of saturated
fat from red meat specifically does
appear to increase the risk of heart
disease by increasing trimethylamine and
oxide it also goes without saying that a
meat only diet can only displace like
really
important nutrients like fiber vitamin c
and other antioxidants that are largely
found in plant-based foods and we know
that a diet completely void of fiber can
have negative implications for our
microbiome while low intakes of
antioxidants like vitamin c carries
increased risks to health but according
to jordan peterson the lack of vitamin c
from the carnivore diet is a non-issue
which brings me to claim number two you
don't need vitamin c
i would assume that you need
phytonutrients i would assume you need
vitamin supplements like vitamin c for
example it turns out if you don't eat
carbohydrates you don't need vitamin c
who would have guessed that how does
that work vitamin c is necessary for
carbohydrate metabolism
not quite like most vitamins and
minerals vitamin c serves more than just
one function in the body so for example
it's involved in collagen and
neurotransmitter production immune
function wound healing iron absorption
and it's also anti-inflammatory due to
its antioxidant properties so yeah i
definitely wouldn't knock the importance
of vitamin c as strictly just a
metabolizer plus vitamin c is actually
involved in protein metabolism by
playing an important role in the
synthesis of collagen l-carnitine
catecholamines and other proteins this
is why vitamin c is essential for wound
repair and healthy brain function along
with a ton of other things with that
said what happens when you're not
getting any vitamin c from the carnivore
diet well
of course this would have immunological
cognitive and dermatological
consequences and in extreme cases you
could develop scurvy which results in
symptoms of fatigue inflammation
depression and in some cases even death
maybe it's none of my business but if
you eat three pounds of steak every day
you're gonna die however proponents of
the carnivore diet argue that you can
apparently obtain enough vitamin c from
a meat only diet to prevent scurvy and
while they're technically not wrong here
since research on inuit communities
suggests that one can obtain vitamin c
from animal organs and raw meat you
would have to eat a lot of meat so for
example you can eat 770 grams of raw
beef liver to get a pathetic 10
milligrams of vitamin c or you can take
a single bite out of an orange your
choice so while carnivore dieters may
have hacked their way into preventing
scurvy by eating more organ meats it's
very unlikely that they would be hitting
the 90 milligram daily vitamin c
recommendation which you can get in like
half a bell pepper without inadvertently
throwing everything else out of whack
lastly proponents of the carnivore diet
are quick to rag on vegetables for their
anti-nutrient properties jordan peterson
never explicitly spoke about this on the
podcast app but i do really want to
quickly debunk this since we're all here
and it does come up quite often now it
is true that some vegetables legumes and
whole grains do contain anti-nutrients
that reduce the absorption of some
vitamins and minerals but in general
anti-nutrients are not a major threat to
our health and the foods that contain
them also contain beneficial nutrients
like fiber vitamins and antioxidants
plus a lot of the anti-nutrient content
contained in certain foods is also
greatly reduced just by cooking them ah
yes civilization has its perks so moving
on to clean number three carnivorism can
cure anxiety and depression quit eating
greens and i thought oh really jesus
michaela i'm eating cucumbers
lettuce
broccoli and chicken and beef it's like
i have to cut out the goddamn greens
it's like try it for a month
okay within a week i was 25 less anxious
in the morning within two weeks 75 and
i've been better every single day i'm
better now probably than i've ever been
in my life and i haven't been taking
antidepressants for a whole year listen
what works for one person's mental
health is not going to work for another
so i will never belittle someone's lived
experience but what does the data say
well there was really only one
retrospective study on the carnivore
diet which used self-reported data aka
pretty much the biased bottom of the
barrel when it comes to study design
quality but anyways so any effect that
the carnivore diet may have on mood
disorders like anxiety and depression is
largely anecdotal and not evidence-based
however we do have some research on the
effects of the keto diet for depression
and given that the carnivore diet is
essentially like a higher protein
version of the keto diet and that it
eliminates carbs and puts the body into
a state of ketosis it does give us a
better idea of what might be going on
neurologically so research suggests that
the keto diet may help to improve
symptoms of anxiety and depression by
increasing circulating levels of the
neurotransmitter gaba which plays a key
role in managing stress anxiety and mood
however more research is needed to fully
understand this mechanism before we can
like recommend the keto diet as a
legitimate treatment for mood disorders
and even if we did have more research to
recommend this as like a possible
adjunct therapy it would never be
recommended that you only eat meat
there's really nothing miraculous about
a rib eye steak that will cure your
depression you would still be able to
eat a variety of other keto friendly
foods other than meat like vegetables
nuts seeds fish and dairy and you'd
probably be happier if you weren't
constipated or losing your teeth due to
scurvy or malnutrition so not today
in fact research suggests that a diet
rich in fruits and vegetables is
associated with a lower risk of
depression so
yeah the logic here just doesn't check
out but back to peterson for a hot
moment because i do find that his
testimony is very powerful so what could
possibly explain his unique ability to
get off his meds well honestly there's a
lot to be unsure about in the world of
mental health research but one thing is
pretty clear that the placebo effect is
real we have lots of compelling evidence
on the power of placebo for anxiety and
depression because a positive placebo
experience can increase mood
neurotransmitters like dopamine and
serotonin and despite a lot of heated
controversy and debate we even have
studies to suggest that placebo
medication may actually produce the same
effect as actual antidepressant
pharmaceuticals now another potential
explanation here is that peterson's
autoimmune disease made him uniquely and
legitimately sensitive to a number of
different foods which he effectively
removed due to the nature of his very
restrictive diet and that brings me to
my next point claim number four
carnivorism cures autoimmune diseases
and my psoriasis disappeared i've had
gum disease since i was 25. that's been
serious enough to have i've had to have
minor surgical interventions scraping
and that sort of thing to keep it at bay
it's gone
i checked with my dentist before this
last tour no inflammation so as i
discussed in my video on downshiftology
which you can watch right here
autoimmune diseases are complicated as
but simply put an autoimmune disease is
a condition where the immune system
attacks part of the body that it
mistakes as foreign even though they're
otherwise perfectly healthy cells so the
first step in alleviating autoimmune
disease symptoms would be to lower the
chronic inflammation and ultimately get
the gut in check to help down regulate
this autoimmune response but because
there's no standard diet protocol for
most autoimmune diseases it ends up
being a lot of trial and error to be
able to kind of like pin down the
specific food triggers which should
ideally be done through an elimination
diet under the supervision of a
registered dietitian so the fact that
jordan peterson claims to have
effectively eliminated his gum disease
and his psoriasis symptoms likely has
less to do with anything miraculous in
the meat and more to do with the fact
that he's eliminating all other foods a
few of which may be triggering for him
in other words we don't need to
eliminate all vegetables when only
broccoli and cauliflower are the ones
triggering symptoms a limited diet
especially when devoid of fiber is the
absolute worst diet for a healthy
microbiome and a healthy microbiome is
really the key to long-term remission
from autoimmune or inflammatory
conditions one of the hypothesis that
we've been pursuing and there's some
justification for this in the scientific
literature is that the reason that you
lay on layers of fat is because the fat
acts as a buffer between you and the
toxic things that you're eating and
maybe when you strip out that protective
layer then you're more sensitive to what
you shouldn't be eating no no no no no
nope time to go back to the drawing
board on the hypothesis here doc science
first of all your body fat doesn't
metabolize food your digestive system
does most importantly your gut and your
gut plays a very important role in
regulating autoimmune disease symptoms
but what we most often see in folks with
autoimmune disease is a weakening of the
integrity of the gut which often results
in intestinal permeability otherwise
known as leaky gut this is why it's so
important to focus on nutrients that
support gut barrier function like
omega-3 fats vitamin d probiotics and
antioxidant rich foods it's also just as
important to focus on food variety to
support a diverse microbiome and
surprise surprise that is not possible
on a meat only diet with all that said
it's important to note that jordan
peterson's experience and success on the
carnivore diet is highly individualized
and likely has to do with severe food
sensitivities and intolerances to a lot
of the foods that he cut out and while
there is a very small possibility that
beef is the only food that is well
tolerated for him although highly
unlikely it's important to keep in mind
that one individual's unusual experience
does not build a case for universal
adoption ultimately the carnivore diet
is overwhelmingly restrictive
unsustainable void of essential
nutrients like fiber and antioxidants
and increases the risk of negative
health consequences like scurvy heart
disease cancer and poor gut health you
don't have to be an abby stan to know
that this is a hard pass for me so on
that note i'm gonna go eat a banana
right now that is all that i have for
you guys today thank you again to seed
for sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with what you would like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]